こんにちははじめ社長ですえこの動画は
ですね特に誰に向けてていうわけでもなく
本当に僕が思ったことを動画にしたいなと
思って撮っています
え本当にありがとうというの
はついに終わりましたね進撃の巨人アニメ
進撃の巨人完結おめでとうございます
はいなんでお前がメインチャンネルでなん
ではじめさんがメインチャンネルで進撃の
巨人の感想出してるですかて言うんです
けどもあのま理由としては僕はめ社長2
っていうこのチャンネルではないサブ
チャンネルっていうゲームとかの動画を
出してるチャンネルがあるんですけどその
チャンネルで進撃の巨人の1話から
ファイナルシーズン前話え出させて
いただきました僕の福音性付きではめ社長
と一緒に進撃の巨人を見ようっていう企画
ででアニメ進撃の巨人の公式さんから許可
をいただいてえ一緒に進撃の巨人のも最後
の方は出てないんですけどラストは出て
ないんですけどそれまでのもう前話え全て
僕が見
て動画に出させていただいたのであなんか
思い入れがあるという
か思い入れどころの話ではないななんか何
年前からやってたんだっけあれかなり昔
からもう一期の1話からずっと動画を出さ
せていただいて
でその歴史ある進撃の巨人というアニメが
え昨日NHKで放送されてついに完結し
まし
たえご覧になった皆さんいかがだった
でしょう
か僕は深夜で眠かったです眠かったけど
決して寝ることなく最後までえエレンたち
の物語を見届けれたかなと思ってますあ
ごめんなさいね新劇の巨人知らない人から
すると新劇の巨人見てないよって人から
するとちょっとあまり深い話はしない方が
いいかなと思うんですけどあれはね本当に
素晴らしい作品ですなんかもうアニメじゃ
ないんですよアニメの意を超えてるという
か表現しづらいなだめだ人並みのコメント
しか出てないけどなんかね歴史です1つの
アニメ界の歴史が
終わったってわけじゃないですけど完結し
てしまったので寂しいなっていう気持ちと
本当に進撃の巨人のえ公式の方そして原作
者の磯山はじめさん
はめ感謝でいっぱいです本当に良かった
最高の作品でしたそしてそのアニメに立っ
てえっと私初めたお信頼してくれてありえ
ない話だったすよこんなしがない
YouTuberのささ誰かもわからん
いや誰か分かるけどこんな俺をはめしたち
っていう人間を信頼してくださって進撃の
巨人のアニメをチャンネルに出してくださ
いっていう許可をいただいて信頼いただい
てありえない量のあんな素敵な作品を僕の
チャンネルに出させていただいて本当に
ありがとうござい
[音楽]
ますそうまずはねえそういう感謝を進撃の
巨人にってる皆様にお伝えしたく動画を
撮ってい
ますいやもうねしびれたね最終回見ました
85分だったんですよ尺アニメでそんな
長いの作るの絶対大変だと思って戦闘
シーンとかもめちゃくちゃすごくてはもう
終わっちゃうんだっ
[音楽]
てこの素晴らしい作品アニメが終わって
しまうんだと思って
なんか作品的な感動もあり言ましたけど
このやっぱ副音声全部つけてきたからその
思い入れもあってああ終わったなって思っ
てしまいまし
[音楽]
た俺作ったわけでもないのになんで泣いて
んだろうま好きな作品だったのでねそれは
もう終わってしまったら悲しいし寂しい
ですよティッシュごめんなさいね見てない
人からするとなんでこいつ泣いてねんと
思いますけど本当良かったんですよ進撃の
巨人まだ見てない方は是非見てみて
くださいこれで最初から最後まで全部出
ました出会いはねもう進撃に巨人との
出会いは漫画の1巻のあの発売日からも
出会ってて漫画の1巻にさ超大型巨人
バンって書いてあってなんか筋肉の筋
だらけで気持ち悪くて何これと思って
なんか不気味な漫画が出たなっていうもう
興味本意で進撃の巨人第1巻を買って呼ん
でああ多分これこの超大型巨人っていう
バカでかいやつを主人公のエレンイエガー
が長座兵団としてぶっ倒せば話が終わるん
だと思ったらそんな話では
なく全く敵が違ったというかもっともっと
もっと深い部分で作品が進んでてなんで壁
に囲まれてるんだろうとか巨人って何なん
だろうっていう疑問色々あったんですけど
も全てを解決させてえ最終回がバシッと
決まったっていう感じではいちょっと是非
見てみて欲しいですね見てない人僕ね何が
嬉しかったかって言うとあのXで進撃の
巨人の最終会が終わった後
そのポストしたんですよ一言新劇の巨人
ありがとうって最高出したってでその
リブラ見てると本当にいろんな人にね
あのはじめのおかげではじめ社長のおかげ
で進撃の巨人に進撃の巨人を知ることが
できたとか知らなかったけど初め社長と
見れて本当にドしたとかこんなに夢中に
なる作品に出会えると思ってなかったとか
なんかなんか知んないですけど俺にも
めっちゃ完成されてすごい
で俺作ってないのにただ本当に素敵な作品
をさあの副音声ってことでちょっとだけ
喋って一緒に見てるだけだったんですけど
なんかね思ったよりたくさんの人に進撃の
巨人を伝えられてたんだなって思って
なんか感謝されてて嬉しいなって思いまし
たなので一緒に撃の巨人を見てくれた人
本当にありがとうございますあの物語は
昨日で終わってしまいましたそれをね
こうなんかねSNSで悪いこと多いじゃん
人のあげ足取ったりさ誰かの悪口書いたり
さ憶測でなんか悪いこと言ったりあんま
好きじゃないんすよSNS最近そんな中
昨日進撃に巨人ありがとうってポストし
たらもうなんかリポストするためにいん人
にお前最高だだよとか本当にありがとうっ
てなんか感謝されててなんかそんな機会
与えてくださったことにも感謝だし一緒に
見てくださったみんなにも感謝してて
なんか感慨深い1つのなんか役目が終わっ
たなって思いました
音声大変だったんですよいい作品だからさ
怪我したくもないし傷つけたくもないから
服
音声すっげえ気をつけてて喋る時大事な
セリフの時にさ俺が喋ってか手も台無しに
なるし喋らなすぎても喋らなすぎてもなん
でいるんだってなるしなんか安梅が難しく
てすごいプレッシャーがあったんですけど
なのですごい大変だったけど作品は
とっても楽しかったしやってよかったなっ
て最終回を迎えた今えいろんな人に感謝さ
れててやってよかったなって思います他の
アニメもやらせてくださいそこがそこも
すごい嬉しかったねあの進撃の巨人って
いうもう最強のアニメの副音声っていうの
をやらせていただいて虚偽反応出る人とか
絶対いるじゃんなんではじめ社長がいいん
だよ邪魔だみたいなうるせえとか結構
初めて社長と毎回見てたて人が多くてあ
なんか受け入れられてて良かったなって俺
のあの福音世のやり方は間違ってなかった
のかなってちょっと思いまし
たはいあの今は全部ないです初め社長通に
アップしてて今全部飛公会になってるん
ですけどもこれはもう大人の事情なので
仕方です甘えないでくださいそんな無料で
アニメいつまででも見れると思ったら大
間違いです大人の事情でえ期間限定で公開
してました今は非行外になってますがもう
全然ネト振りとかAmazonプライムと
かサブスクいろんなところで見れるし最終
回もどうなんだろうもう見れるのかなそれ
がそのうち見れるようになるのかな
ちょっとわかんないですけど進撃の巨人は
全部出たので是非見てみてくださいアニメ
の感想話せるだけでメイン出すのかって
ちょっと俺も疑問に思ったけどこれだけは
ね本当に言いたかったアニメ進撃の巨人を
チャンネルに出させていただけてたって
いうこの奇跡的な歴史的な解俺すごいと
思うのよ俺自分すごいと思うもんこれ
ばかりはあの作品で携われてたことそして
あのアニメが昨日終わってしまったって
ことそしてなんか自分が想像していた以上
にいろんな人に副音声はめ社長の動画で
見れて進撃の巨人を知れてよかった本当に
ありがとうっていろんな人に言ってもらえ
たことこれ
は動画にす
べき内容なのかなと思ってメイン
チャンネルで撮らせていただいてます本当
にお疲れ様でした制作の皆様えぐかった
だろうな85分の最終はもうだって戦闘
シーンとか見まし
たすごすぎたよもう皆さんはどのシーンが
好きだったでしょうかもうかなりの人見て
たと思うのよなんかXもトレンド
めちゃくちゃ乗ってたしもう昨日は本当に
歴史的な1日だったと思うんですけれども
進撃の巨人は本当にあれこそ未来英語に
語り継がれるべき美しくそしてはなく
悲しく切ない人間である以上あれ見たら
感情多少は動くんじゃないかなって思う
よう
な本当になんか学校の授業で見せてあげて
ほしいですそれぐらいなんかこう戦いとか
人の憎しみ合いとか恨み合いとか裏切りと
かいろんなことを学ぶことができた歴史的
アニメだったと思います本当にもう進撃の
巨人進撃の巨人に携わることができて本当
に幸せでしたありがとうございました心臓
[音楽]
捧げよ
お